Drohnen können nicht unendlich groß werden, weil
sie nicht unendlich große Batterien transportieren
können. Satelliten müssen als Ballast auch
immer noch einen Akku mitschleppen. Und bei
Elektroautos macht der Akku ungefähr ein Drittel
des Gesamtgewichts aus. Was passiert aber sobald
ein Akku gar nichts mehr wiegt? Das haben sich
auch Forschende gedacht: Machen wir doch das
gesamte Auto oder den Laptop oder das Smartphone
selbst zur Batterie. Wie das funktioniert und ob
bald wirklich alles um uns herum ein Akku sein
kann, das zeigen wir euch in diesem Video.
Bisher galt immer: Je mehr Power, desto größer
und schwerer der Akku. Das endet in so paradoxen
Konstruktionen wie dass die Batterien zum
Beispiel in Autos immer schwerer werden müssen,
nur um sich selbst herumzufahren. Über
zusätzliche Reichweite kann man erst
danach nachdenken. Deswegen glauben viele
Forschende, dass zum Beispiel Schiffe oder
Flugzeuge nicht im großen Stil elektrisch
werden können. Das Gewicht der benötigten
Batterie wäre zu groß. Wenn aber das Gerät selbst
der Akku wäre, dann könnte sich das alles ändern.
Also, wie kann das funktionieren? Ein Gerät, das
einfach selbst seine Batterie ist? Das Zauberwort
hier heißt: Strukturbatterie. Davon gibt es zwei
verschiedene Varianten. Da gibt es einmal die
Batteriezellen, die ohne Gehäuse einfach direkt
ins Gerät eingebaut werden. Beim neuen Tesla
zum Beispiel bilden die Batteriezellen den Boden
des Autos. Das spart Metall, das man sonst dafür
gebraucht hätte. Eine ähnliche Technik wird schon
für Kerosin bei Flugzeugen angewandt: Anstatt wie
früher einen Tank in den Flügel zu bauen, spart
man sich das Gewicht und der Tank ist der Flügel.
Bei der “richtigen” Strukturbatterie gibt
es jedoch nicht mal mehr Batteriezellen:
Stattdessen wird das ganze Auto,
oder Flugzeug, oder was auch immer,
zum Akku. Seine Einzelteile speichern die
Energie. Hierfür braucht es – wie bei einer
normalen Batterie auch – ein Material, das
den Pluspol bildet, eines, das den Minuspol
bildet, einen Separator dazwischen und ein
Leitermaterial, ein sogenanntes Elektrolyt.
Klingt einfach, ist es aber natürlich –
Überraschung – nicht. Denn anstatt diese
Teile jetzt einfach in einen Kasten zu
packen, wie bei einer normalen Batterie,
muss das Material in die Form eines Autos
oder Flugzeugs gebracht werden. Es muss also
bei der Herstellung verformbar sein. Zusätzlich
muss es sowohl ein guter Energiespeicher sein,
als auch sehr robust. Und häufig sind Materialien
entweder das eine oder das andere. Als wäre das
alles nicht genug, verändert sich das Material
auch noch, wenn es geladen ist. Das müssen
die Hersteller exakt berechnen können, bevor sie
anfangen, groß in die Technologie zu investieren.
Hört sich alles so an, als wäre diese eierlegende
Wollmilchsau unmöglich zu produzieren. Doch eine
Annäherung an dieses Wundermaterial
hat ein Forschungsteam aus Schweden
geschafft. Dafür haben sie folgendes kombiniert:
Kohlenstofffasern bilden den Negativpol, eine mit
Lithiumeisenphosphat beschichtete Aluminiumfolie
den Positivpol. Glasfasern separieren das Ganze,
damit es nicht zum Kurzschluss kommt. Und das
Elektrolyt besteht ebenfalls aus einem festen
Material – damit erhöht es die Belastungsfähigkeit
weiter. Anschließend steckten die Forschenden das
Ganze unter Druck in einen Ofen, um es weiter
auszuhärten. Das sorgt unter anderem für eine
besondere Dünne der Glasfasern. Was wiederum zu
der besonders guten Performance dieser Batterie
beigetragen hat. Und fertig ist sie, die
Batterie, die gleichzeitig Baustoff ist.
Eine Strukturbatterie, die 24 Wattstunden pro
Kilogramm speichert. Zum Vergleich: Diesel oder
Benzin schaffen 11.000 bis 12.000 Wattstunden
pro Kilogramm. Normale Autobatterien rangieren
aktuell um 200 Wattstunden. Einzelne Hersteller
sprechen bereits von einer Feststoffbatterie mit
bis zu 400 Wh/kg. Man muss also ganz ehrlich
sagen: Marktreif ist die neue Strukturbatterie
noch lange nicht. Andererseits muss sie ja auch
rund ein Drittel weniger Gewicht transportieren.
In Sachen Robustheit performte diese
neue Batterie wiederum sehr gut:
Ihre “Steifigkeit”, also die
Robustheit des Materials,
lag bei 25 Gigapascal. Mit dieser Kombi
aus Speicherkapazität und Steifigkeit
schlägt der neue Akku laut den Forschenden
also alle bisherigen Strukturbatterien.
In Zukunft wollen die Forschenden auch die
Aluminiumfolie durch Kohlefasern ersetzen.
Sie hoffen, dadurch die Steifigkeit und
die Energiedichte auf 75 Wattstunden pro
Kilogramm noch weiter zu steigern. Wir haben
den Forschungsgruppenleiter Leif Asp nach
dem Stand der Dinge gefragt: Ein weiteres
Kohlenstofffaser-Aluminiumfolie-Material mit rund
41 Wattstunden pro Kilogramm ist
gerade fertig geworden und das
Paper hierzu wird nun peer reviewed. An der
Kohlenstofffaser-Kohlenstofffaser-Batterie
arbeiten sie und eine weitere
schwedische Forschungsgruppe parallel.
Ok. Es gibt also erste Schritte, noch einen weiten
Weg zu gehen, aber auch jetzt schon Ideen, wie die
aktuellen Probleme gelöst werden könnten. Super!
Wann wird denn dann alles aus Batterie sein?
Forschende gehen davon aus, dass es noch gut
zehn Jahre dauern könnte, bis wir die ersten
Autos haben, die gleichzeitig Batterie und
Auto sind. Auch, weil die Entwicklung von
Akkus feingenerell sehr langwierig und teuer ist.
Ihr habt sicher alle schon von Graphen-, Luft-,
Keramik- oder Glasbatterien gehört, die zwar im
Labor toll, aber noch lange nicht marktreif sind.
Aber Autos sind vielleicht auch die Königsklasse
– sie brauchen verhältnismäßig viel Energie und
müssen wahnsinnig viele Sicherheitsauflagen
erfüllen. In kleineren Geräten könnte das
Konzept schon deutlich eher angewendet
werden. Manche Wissenschaftler und
Wissenschaftlerinnen liebäugeln zum Beispiel mit
einem Einsatz in Mikrogeräten aus der Medizin,
die kleiner als eine Fingerkuppe sind.
Diese könnten so noch kleiner werden.
Also wird diese Batterie all unsere Gewichts-
und Platzprobleme mit Akkus lösen? Wir wissen
es noch nicht. Denn vielleicht ist die
Technik gar nicht das non-plus-ultra:
Es ist zum Beispiel noch unklar, ob und wie solche
Geräte repariert werden könnten. Bei den Batterien
als Bauteil wie im Tesla geht das laut einigen
ersten Tüftlern wohl quasi gar nicht. Und auch
bei den “echten” Strukturbatterien
gibt es noch einige Unklarheiten:
Wenn ein Kratzer am Auto gleichzeitig ein
Kratzer an der Batterie bedeutet – muss
man dann direkt alles austauschen? Und
wie sieht das mit dem Recycling aus,
wenn das Gerät aus so stark miteinander
verwobenen Materialien besteht?
Ihr seht, noch ist das Ganze Zukunftsmusik.
Aber die Forschenden klingen recht optimistisch,
dass es Strukturbatterien – zumindest für
einige Geräte – in Zukunft geben könnte.
Manchmal würde ich gerne wetten,
welche dieser ganzen bahnbrechenden
neuen Batterietypen und Energiequellen
zuerst marktreif werden. Bestimmt die
kalte Kernfusion. Ihr wisst schon.
Nur noch dreißig Jahre und so.
Bis dahin, bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric